welcome to another dr sadler's honest
review this is a book review series in
which i look at largely
recent literature in the domain of
practical philosophy very broadly
speaking so that means not just
philosophy as a way of life or ethics or
philosophy applied to personal
development but also
self-help and
leadership management organizational
behavior really anything where ideas
can come into practice
the book that i'm reviewing this time
this very little volume here is one that
slipped past my notice and what do i
mean by that well it's by a friend and
colleague of mine john sellers and it
was published in
2019. now john publishes quite a lot of
stuff but somehow this escaped my
notice and i was fortunate enough that
it came in a bunch of books that a
friend of mine sent to me
and i looked at it i said well this this
looks quite interesting i read it last
night and i'm going to be passing this
on to
a family member that i think can greatly
benefit from it it is called the pocket
stoic and it is you know quite literally
a pocket book small enough to fit into
the back pocket on your pants or you
know on your jacket or maybe even a
shirt pocket depending on how how big
they are
now it's about um
100 pages a little bit over that but
they're quite small
and
there's a lot to say about this this
short book i think this will be a rather
short review because um there there is
just only so much to it but i'm gonna
actually front load this and say
this is a good book for even for
somebody who's you know an advanced
student of stoicism you can get
something
out of this but this is a really great
book i think for beginners and this
would make an awesome
gift to somebody if you're interested in
stoicism and you already are kind of far
along the way this would be an excellent
way to introduce somebody else to it
so first thing i usually talk about the
big three s's a summary of the work
style
and structure so let's start with
structure
it's pretty straightforward it's divided
into these seven chapters each of which
are divided off by a little black page
and you know nice uh
what do you want to call this you know a
title
set of pages right and then it goes
right into the discussion you can see
that you know it's a hundred pages long
but you're not packing all that much on
each page
maybe 100 150 words tops i would guess
and so it's a quick read
there are these seven chapters it's
divided in in very sensible ways
the philosopher's doctor is kind of a
nice way to start we'll talk about that
a little bit more when we get to the
next section
what do you control plastic stoic
doctrine right the problem with emotions
dealing with adversity our place in
nature life and death
how we live together and then there's an
epilogue there's also a prologue to it
and there are some nice features to this
i think again for a beginner there is a
further reading section which is always
nice to have right and it's um
you know it's it's a decent there's also
the references as well
to
what texts are being talked about so the
further reading is about
four pages
and it includes you know what you'd
expect the works of the three roman
stoix it has suggestions for which
translations to get
along with you know the penguin great
ideas series
and there's there's the reference to the
complete works of lucius anea seneca
released by the university of chicago
press one references to
irvine donald robertson holliday and
hanselman
massimo pigliucci and then pierre ado
long and emily
wilson
um then there's john inwood and or
bradenwood and john sellers and there's
also a little thing here blurb about
stoic week and modern stoicism.com
which is a great place to go so you know
you've got a lot of stuff packed in here
the
style so sellers this is not his first
book he's written a lot of books and
john sellers
is one of the the rare people who can
write
really well as an academic
and also really well in popular writing
and can bridge the gap in between
and that's essentially what you're
getting here you're getting something
that's
i won't say rigorous in the sense of
going deep into the text but it is
rigorous in the sense he's not he's not
making any mistakes right
and he's introducing you to the key
ideas they're judiciously chosen there's
short passages that are being referenced
so it's you know as a style very
readable but also
um on point you could say
and what is it how should we summarize
this well it's a little handbook a
little pocket book that is designed as
it says in the prologue to get you into
studying stoicism he actually begins by
saying what if someone told you much of
the suffering in your life was simply
due to the way you think about things
then he says well that's what the stoics
actually said so that's what we're going
to discuss and that's precisely what he
does through the text
what are some of the key points of this
well they're revealed in the chapter
titles uh we'll go back over those very
quickly again
and i'll bring a few other things to
light i really do like his beginning
with epictetus and the saying about the
philosophy school as being a doctor's
office now this is before anesthetic
right and doctors would do things like
set your bones and you just had to grin
and bear it and he says you know the
philosopher is a doctor the
philosopher's school is a hospital for
not the body but for
souls so you know expect it to be work
and and there's this talk about the care
of the soul the character of the person
what should we be paying attention to
and then it brings in zeno
um
epictetus again going back to that and
you know bringing up some of the big
picture stuff about the stoics and then
the next chapter begins with what the
stoics called the dichotomy of control
this division between the things that we
actually can determine and the things
that lie outside of our absolute
determining right it's not as if we
can't choose what we do with our bodies
or our money but
something else enters into the picture
with that and this is a very important
stoic doctrine um you know there's
there's a lot of uh
short introspection about what what we
actually
do
sometimes say we don't have control over
like our judgments and the what happens
when we make mistakes with this the next
one the problem with emotions goes into
the
stoic
theory of the emotions and brings up
mostly focusing on anger
as as a prime example bringing in
chrysippus view and seneca's
work on anger but it does also
discuss some of the other what the
stoics view as harmful emotions and
stresses that stoics are not unemotional
and brings in i think very helpfully a
nice little discussion about
uh parental love or or you know what we
often call familial affection
the philoso chapter dealing with
adversity how is it that we can
deal with the things that happen it
brings up uh seneca's case and
i think sellers very helpfully points
out that
although seneca was rich his life was
not an easy one he was exiled for quite
a while
um he you know endured illness he had to
deal with a crazy emperor right and lots
of friends who needed to be consoled so
you know what is it that will in fact
make us happy and then here he peers in
again about
things that are in our control you know
our emotional states whether we develop
virtue or not things that are outside of
our control have less to do with our
happiness there's also a
good discussion in here of grief seneca
is probably one of the
more easy going stoics on on grief right
and and that's a key thing that we're
going to
run into
there's a discussion in chapter 5 of our
place in nature the stoics quite
famously thought that there was you know
the vast world itself that we are parts
of
and that we also have a distinctively
human nature which needs to be
cultivated sellers does a good job in
explaining this right and how we are
often parts of holes he talks also as
well about how the ancient stoics viewed
nature as this providentially
ordering because nature itself is driven
by a logos a mind behind it and then you
know talks about whether we have to
think about this way or or not and looks
at marcus aurelius as somebody who says
adams or providence i'm still going to
do the same thing
the next chapter
has to do with death so we return back
to this theme
human you know
mortality rate is 100 percent over any
given point in time it's one of those
things that really tends to produce
problems for us and
sellers zeroes in on some of the key
texts like seneca's on the shortness of
life that help us to
deal with these these uh existential
unavoidable conditions
the final one how we live together this
stress is a really important part of
stoicism
quite often people
think that stoicism means being
unemotional we've already dealt with
that in an earlier chapter but it also
means withdrawing from society and if
you look at the ancient stoics they did
not do that at all
and sellers brings that out i'm just
going to read one little
portion here we are not individual
isolated entities we are part of nature
the stoics would agree with aristotle
when he said human beings are by nature
social and political animals we are born
into communities
the stoic turn inwards as we've seen is
primarily focused on cultivating good
virtuous character traits and avoiding
harmful
anti-social emotions such as anger the
whole point of it is that afterwards we
turn back outwards to play our parts as
more effective members of the various
communities of which we're necessarily
apart i really like that that
formulation and this is a good example
of sellers
bringing things together i mean he's
been studying this for decades bringing
these key points together to make a
larger well-structured point and that is
that's the last chapter in it there is
um you know a short epilogue
talking about um how the how the stoics
you know were read also in the middle
ages but then it talks about the present
and i'll just read you one more passage
since 2012 so this is written in 2019
over 20 000 people have taken part in a
global online experiment to see if
living like a stoic for a week might
improve their sense of well-being the
results suggest it does those who have
followed a month-long experiment saw
even greater
benefits he's talking about the stoic
mindfulness and resilience training
stuff so you know that's what this book
is basically talking about
you can get it and read it in the space
of an afternoon uh quite quickly maybe
even in the course of an hour if you're
already very familiar with the ideas
so that's some of the key points
so i think by this point you can tell
that i'm a fan of this little work what
other good points do i need to say about
it than those i've already highlighted
well i want to stress a point that i've
already made briefly namely that sellers
is very good at taking little bite-sized
chunks of ideas from seneca or epictetus
or marcus aurelius or some of the other
stoics that he talks about
and
bringing them together and he's chosen
them very well right so he's chosen the
really essential stuff and then he
brings them together
and forges them into coherent holes that
are more than the sum of their parts and
that's what's going on in a lot of this
i think the examples that he uses are
quite well chosen i think he's giving
just enough background
about these key stoic figures uh for
people to you know be interested for the
the history of these people to kind of
help you say oh i i get it but not to
overwhelm you as a matter of fact this
entire book is not overwhelming but it's
not underwhelming either it's just right
it's like a goldilocks thing so i'll say
that i think you know it's it's also got
kind of an attractive
look to it both with the cover and with
the
design of the book university of chicago
did a good job on this one
and you know i think it's well well
thought out well laid out so
the other thing i'll mention again is
that john sellers is very good at
writing
works that retain some academic
structure and rigor but are oriented
towards a popular audience i will be
giving this
to
my mother-in-law as a gift before too
long because i think she'll really enjoy
it and um
you know she's she's uh taking college
classes and actually earned several
degrees but i think this could be given
to just about anybody and they would
benefit highly from from reading it it's
not of course if you're studying
stoicism
it's a nice read
if you already know all this stuff
it's you know it's good
you're not going to learn
radically new things from it but i think
for somebody who hasn't been exposed to
it this would actually be a great
first step perhaps one of the best
is there anything that i would say is
problematic about this work there are no
errors at all which is kind of striking
because usually i can find something
where i'm like well i don't know about
that you know none in this book at all
um
so the things that i would say are
problematic are purely subjective and
one of them is going to strike you is
very very funny so you notice how big my
hands are and you know i can easily grip
this book
i actually find it kind of hard myself
because the book is so small
to
you know read around in it because my my
fingers are so big but
i'm on the large side of that sort of
thing that's probably not going to be an
issue for most people um it is designed
to be a pocketbook so it's got it's got
to fit a certain size right
um the price is you know
some people might say 12 is a little
high for this but
you know it's really well put together
um
it's nicely laid out it's aesthetically
pleasing it's it's it's a book that's
quite good so those would just be
quibbles that one could bring up i i
don't have anything else that's
problematic in any way about this this
book
all right so final thoughts a little bit
of wrap up um i
unreservedly recommend this book i think
it's a great little book
and i think it would be something that
would be best
circulating around as sort of an
introduction to stoicism as i mentioned
already
this was gifted to me i'm going to
continue that gifting by giving it to
somebody else who i think will benefit
from it who has an interest in stoicism
and this will hopefully spark more of it
and give her some solid structure and
then maybe she might pass it on to
somebody else which i think would
actually fit very well with some of the
thematics of this book so
i recommend it and
i think that if this is the sort of
thing that you want or even more so if
you know somebody who
would derive some benefit from it give
it to them as a gift
you